going back to that hard moment this dark
place you went in
in your mind in your personal life story
you lost your husband
um what gave you strength during that
time uh what were the what were the
places you went to your mind
in terms of
personal struggle in terms of maybe even
depression or
or these kinds of struggles
i think for me
when my person passed away
i
went
to
maybe my friend could see what was going
on maybe they couldn't i don't know
but on the surface i looked like i was
fine but what happened is the only thing
i think that kept me around aft as i
thought about it
uh was um
the job to be done
these women relied on me and i was no
longer free i did not own myself and
they said it in those words you don't
own yourself anymore
and it was true
but it helped me because
i was able to um
you know sometimes whatever it takes to
keep you around whatever it takes and
that's what i would tell people who feel
like they can't just push one more push
and they think they need to end it
at that point whatever it takes just
stick around for one more second because
the next second you know
so
i stuck around because of duty i felt a
very strong sense of duty my duty was in
this case i think stronger than my than
my pain
i don't know if it's possible i don't
know how that was possible but it was
and
and i just
pushed my grief under the rug for years
for years i worked like a mad lady
i travel i would travel i would do three
states in three days landing at twin the
morning
around five or six going to ride along
with our distributors because it was
beverage and just keep going and have
all of this energy and look like
everything is fine but what happened was
just like i was focused on the job to be
done and sometimes it is okay to do that
at least for me
it was my safety my you know like when
you're in the water and you're about to
sink and they throw you that um that
round thing i don't know how you call it
um you know but uh
you know that keeps you afloat yes yes
yeah whatever
between the two of us
we're still terrible
i know exactly what you mean exactly
right so you understand me so they sent
you that thing and you just i was just
hanging on to it
my life depended on this thing so these
women
they carried me yeah they carried me
and with time
things are moving forward
and at some point i went into really
really deep depression and um
i went into a very dark place even
darker than when i think i came from
because by that time
i had worked for years on this company
and now some other things was happening
and around that time
it's also when i was discovering
a lot of what i'm we talked about today
about what makes the country rich and
for me to understand that
um
my network i was very much into um left
oriented network
and um
to
to just start to
to see all of this
i tried to address it to realize that
many of these people would prefer go
running for the hills
then
except for a moment
that maybe capitalism might be part of a
solution
when many of them were involved in
capitalism
so um
that was a hard time
at some point i was um
yeah so many things were happening
around that time
that basically shook
up
everything for me
one is hard to talk about because it's
very personal and the person that i that
was but i but i was having a problem
with passed away last year
and i'm one to always say
leave the dead alone
so
because of that i won't speak about it
but there too having a major fallout
with somebody who was like a father
figure for me somebody that i completely
trusted
and so
at some point you just tell ask yourself
was my whole life built on a lie
right
and um and then you're confused and then
you become confused
and
and then at some point you lose 90 of
your friends because of ideologically
speaking it doesn't work anymore
um
[Music]
then you just wonder
have i
have i been asleep this whole time
and then you start to wonder remember
when you ask me who am i
at some point lex
i literally was like a candle in the
wind
i felt like i was a candle in the wind
and it was very hard to come back from
that and um
people have a heart
the few people i talk to about this they
have a hardest time understanding or
even believing it because they're like
you
i'm like yes me
i used to be a candle in the wind
what got you out what made you overcome
that
my current husband
my current husband love love
see when i tell you love is the answer
but him he came with love
but he also came with
um
really helping me figure out the world
so with michael because that's him who
we're talking about michael strong
um
that must be special he's so special
he's supposed so special so you have no
idea how special he is
but you know um michael the reason why i
have such love respect and admiration
for my husband i'll never say it enough
is because um actually it's one of those
relationships that got built based on
intellect first you see
at some point
i was in the position where
i could start a foundation
after having built my first business
and all i wanted
was
an ability to
um power
as many
especially women african women
entrepreneurs like me a few years ago
before then
to do something like i was able to do
bring back to the world some really cool
aspects of our culture built into a
really cool brand 21st century type
that's what i wanted to do because the
more i could promote women like that and
put steam behind them
and the more
my dream envisioned for and respected
africa prosperous africa would happen
back then that's what i wanted
and around me this was also part of a
whole
crisis of um ideologies i had back then
everybody was like well
we we should be just doing grants
and i knew that i my people didn't need
grants they didn't need like a handout
they don't want your charity
i didn't want charity
i wanted someone who could work with me
on my accounting i wanted somebody who
um could help me brainstorm marketing
wise i wanted somebody or i needed to
raise money to um pay my um my research
and development guy to help me you know
take the juices from
my grandma's recipe to something that
can be shelf-stable
i
i uh if you're gonna i needed coaching
these are all the things that i needed
to make my dream happen i didn't want
you to give me some crap for free that's
not what i want i just want um to be
able to build my business with all the
things that business building needs
and so
and so that's what i wanted to do and
this what it was needed
and so
michael
somebody found out about what i was
doing because back in the days in some
ways school they would write a lot about
me and everything and um
uh so michael along with john mackey the
founder of whole foods market they had a
non-profit called flow
and it's all about human flourishing
they want for people everybody to get
this choice this ability to be able to
get to a point in their life where
they're in complete flow it's uh mikhail
just make high michael is the only one
who can say that last name but you know
the whole concept of flow when you're in
a state of flow you're basically doing
what you need what you're supposed to do
the way you're supposed to do it with
people
this whole concept of flow yeah it's
amazing flourishing at the size so you
know so i meet with this man you
next you're so okay so i so we we
he finds me his people find me
and then there was a program where it
was all about accelerating accelerating
women entrepreneurs
so it's during these times that i'm
starting now to see things that's when
actually all of this stuff that i
noticed how come here it takes me all
this time to start my business over the
first 20 minutes here it's free
otherwise thousands of dollars all of
this nonsense that i just took oh maybe
it's just because we messed up we're
poor that's why everything is so messed
up
whoa these people are introducing me to
concepts i'm like first of all i'm like
oh really um
what did you call um the uh doing
business in the right what is that
um you know all of this stuff yeah and
i'm starting to discover this whole of
the body of work
what the free markets like this thing
that i was sensing this environment that
i was sensing that it was different
around me
and that they called it the free markets
over here i never very bad
and then i started to
butt had those ideas with the ideas that
i was fed with before that
and the evidence won
and further more than the evidence the
evidence combined with my lived
experience
it was so powerful so
i basically unders started understanding
these ideas from the most visceral part
of my my body you know of my being
and
it makes sense
so michael
michael
helped me find the solution the answer
to my lifelong little girls question
of why do they have this and we don't
and how do some countries like mine
be poor while others are rich
and
with the we've learned with
understanding all of that
the greatest
biggest sense
of liberation
came upon me like
i i have no other word to describe that
true liberation the liberation that
comes from a peer
to finally
understand and be vindicated
in your own
you know
understand in your own um
deep knowing or
feeling that
they're not what they're saying is not
true you're not the problem it's not you
there's something else
and when i discovered that my whole life
changed so and since then
i have be i've been very serious about
going deeper and deeper and deeper into
my understanding of all of this
understanding the subtlety
at some point i was very angry about the
liberators of africa because i was like
yes you helped liberate us
but just to keep us in this mannerism
i was angry for the longest time
and then eventually you have to engage
empathy
and love
to put yourself in their shoes and try
to understand the time at which they
were living and that got me onto a
journey of trying to understand history
more
that's how i understood i was able to go
beyond just these liberators and try to
understand and rebuild the world around
them at the mark at the micro and under
also at the other macro level
just really you have to try to walk in
their shoes
and from there
finally separate the baby with a bath
water but they were not able to do back
then that's why today
i'm sorry but i have no patience for the
blm organizers founders
especially founders i don't know what
organizers think but the founders told
us what they stand for and i said guys
don't make that same mistake again if
you're serious about this you cannot
make the same mistake
the liberals of africa
they have an excuse
we didn't know better it was it was so
easy back then to conflate everything
but today
you me anybody alive
cannot with a straight face
embrace marxist socialist ideas
especially especially
when they're claiming that they want
people
to thrive
no you can't i'm sorry
and i will hold you i will hold your
feet up to the fire on that one i will i
will and that's what i'm doing they will
give me a lot of grief for this but
guess what i could care less do you know
why i could care less
because we have an entire population
to help rise
out of poverty into prosperity where
they become
you know co-creators
global co-creators of innovation
and those ideas give you hope for the
place you love for senegal for africa
they do
they do i live the world i live in
the new centers of culture and fashion
are in dhaka
the new um the new the new centers of uh
tech and
and um
you know crypto even
is somewhere maybe nigeria so you see
that future you see that future clearly
i do i do
i do
it's a beautiful thing and uh it's also
beautiful to see that the space of these
uh really powerful ideas is where you
also fall in love right so at the
intersection at the section michael
would spend mike and i would spend hours
talking about all of his ideas and i
would be like but what about this no it
doesn't make any sense no no no oh no
and then hours every single day for
months lex yeah
and then from there our love was born
because i tell people
for us love is not about looking for in
the eyes like you know we all think but
it's about we look in one direction and
in this case it's this vision what we
know to be possible and true if only
you liberate people
we what we know to be true and possible
we all of us are miracles walking around
every time i get on a plane it's a
miracle of engineering
um all the things we're able to do you
know now when they do operation on your
teeth how they're able to put the pain
down away all of this is us you're
working on these robots
this this this inside here yeah humans
are amazing i know
so that's why i went and when it works
in great tandem with this guy yeah yeah
these two working together yeah
watch out nothing we can't accomplish
nothing nothing
you